es gibt besteht wenig über das
physikerinnen und physiker so heißt
debattieren wir über die stringtheorie
denn da fängt es schon an handelt es
sich überhaupt um eine theorie wenn man
sie weder beweisen noch widerlegen kann
dennoch ist auch klar die stringtheorie
schafft es nicht nur die struktur der
materie in ihren kleinsten bausteine
sondern zeitgleich auch das universum im
großen und ganzen zu erklären quasi eine
theorie von allem eine super spannende
sache also und so habt ihr euch das als
thema für dieses video gewünscht auf
whatsapp alle wichtigen facts thing
theorie bekommt ihr also jetzt herzlich
willkommen zu sein sind action
erstens die stringtheorie kurz und knapp
erklärt mit unseren vorstellungen von
einem dreidimensionalen raum in dem wir
uns in unserem alltag bewegen kommt man
bezüglich der stringtheorie nicht sehr
weit denn hier gibt es einfach gesagt
viel mehr als links und rechts und hoch
und runter und vorwärts rückwärts
stringtheorie täter gehen davon aus dass
es sehr viel mehr dimensionen gibt ein
weiterer punkt der stringtheorie es wird
davon ausgegangen dass materie nicht aus
atomen oder noch kleineren teilchen
besteht sondern eben aus strings die
sich in einer 10 dimensionalen raumzeit
bewegen vorzustellen wie fäden oder
linien die wie die saiten einer gitarre
schwingen und der folgende effekt
sprengt unsere vorstellungskraft noch
einmal mehr denn einige dimensionen
sollen quasi eingerollt sein also ein
bisschen so wie wenn man ein foto des
universums zusammenrollt aber der ansatz
ist auf jeden fall super spannend nicht
materie stößt sich hier gegenseitig ab
sondern schwingungen also dass hier das
sind quasi schwingungen die irgendwie
nicht zusammen kommen die wahl oder
licht ja wo wir auch nichts zu fassen
bekommen verhält sie sich auch mit der
materie nur dass sie anders miteinander
reagiert eine absolut spannende
vorstellung alles sind nur schwingungen
strings zweitens wie und warum ist die
stringtheorie entstanden ja ins leben
gerufen wurde in die stringtheorie durch
experimente mit protonen kollisionen wie
beispielsweise am lhc dem large hadron
collider bei genf denn tatsächlich wirkt
es so als seien die einzelnen quarks
durch elastische fäden miteinander
verbunden und so haben teams aus
theoretischen physikern und physiker
sind schon vor einiger zeit versucht
die eigenschaften der sogenannten
patronen mit dem schwing verhalten
eindimensionaler seiten beziehungsweise
vreden zu erklärt konzert 70 kamen dann
die ersten swing theorien heraus aber es
sollte noch mindestens 30 jahre dauern
ehe dann so etwas wie ein durchbruch in
sachen strings erzielt werden konnte
drittens wurde ist die stringtheorie
überhaupt zu gebrauchen
es ist keineswegs so dass die
stringtheorie in den labor kellern
dieser welt verrottet im gegenteil denn
sie hat eine sache tatsächlich geschafft
ihr wisst es vielleicht dass man sowohl
die quantenmechanik als auch die
allgemeine relativitätstheorie als
eckpfeiler der physik bezeichnen kann
beide sind rund 100 jahre alt und auch
wenn sie sich bestens bewährt haben kann
man sie nicht wirklich zusammen bringen
doch die stringtheorie ist die heißeste
kandidatin dafür
durch sie können theoretische
unvereinbarkeiten zwischen der
quantenphysik und der allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie von albert einstein
erstmals aufgelöst werden das besondere
an strings ist zudem dass man mit ihnen
objekte bilden kann
die schwarzen löchern ähneln und
schwarze löcher wiederum sind großartig
um die quanten aspekte der gravitation
zu erforschen in den 90er jahren gab es
dann in diesem zusammenhang den großen
durchbruch es ging um hadronen also alle
teilchen die quarks enthalten die
forschungsteams fanden damals heraus
dass es nicht nur eine einzige theorie
für diakonische physik gibt stattdessen
entdeckten sie neue modelle mit denen
sich die stringtheorie in einer fünf
dimensionalen raumzeit beschreiben lässt
und das bedeutet auch wir sind nicht in
der lage zu unterscheiden ob die reale
welt vier oder fünf dimensional ist es
kommt stattdessen auf die perspektive an
nämlich obwohl sie als eine welt aus
teilchen oder eben aus strings aus fäden
betrachten physikalisch gesehen hat
jedenfalls beide dieser beschreibung
ihrer vorzüge der vorteil der
stringtheorie sie beschreibt vor allem
große abstände zwischen den quarks sehr
gut das kann die quanten chrome oder
namik nicht so verlässlich liefern
viertens wie kann man die stringtheorie
visualisieren oder gar messen
ein forschungsteam vom max planck
institut für gravitationsphysik hatte
2016 gemeldet dass sie die versteckten
dimensionen des trinks entdeckt haben
und zwar in gravitationswellen
die existenz von gravitationswellen
hatte bereits albert einstein
vorausgesagt doch er bezweifelte damals
noch dass man ihre existenz jemals
nachweisen könnte möglich wurde das dann
durch die beiden lego detektoren in den
usa wo steht für laser interferometer
gravitation wave observatorio doch was
hat das mit links zu tun
das forschungsteam hatte berechnet dass
die zusätzlichen dimensionen der
raumzeit die die string theorie
voraussagt auswirkungen auf die
gravitationswellen struktur haben könnte
und genau dies müsste man nachweisen um
die stringtheorie zumindest indirekt zu
bestätigen die detektoren für
gravitationswellen sind dafür allerdings
momentan nicht empfindlich genug für die
bestätigung müssen wir also noch auf den
riesigen gravitationswellen gedeckter
leiser warten
der zwischen sonne und erde gebaut wird
und der ja frühestens irgendwann in den
2030er jahren voraussichtlich starten
wird
fünftens wie sieht die zukunft der
stringtheorie aus im gegensatz zu
anderen rechen techniken steckt die
stringtheorie quasi noch in den
kinderschuhen
ihre entwicklung ist mühselig und zeit
intensiv geforscht wird dazu
beispielsweise am deutschen
elektronen-synchrotron desy in hamburg
fest steht aber solange es nicht mehr
hinweise zur stringtheorie gibt wird
auch die diskussion um sie nicht beendet
sein wenn ihr also nicht so sting
theorie und zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollen oder als erstes
informiert werden wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp und in
anderen messengern dann erfahrt ihr von
mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
täglich garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken unsere begrüßen habe ich
ein kleines goodie und natürlich nicht
das abo mit der genau glocke vergessen
und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken gravitationswellen jetzt
geht die forschung richtig los ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran